Let's look at the solution to our
write-update optimization quiz
where we have two cores with
write-update coherence and
we consider the case of no optimization,
dirty-bit only optimization,
and both dirty-bit and
shared-bit optimization.
And for this program, how many bus
uses and memory writes do we get?
So, let's consider the case
of no optimization first.
Let us first consider
the no optimization case.
This right here we'll use the bus and
we'll write to memory.
This read here,
the first one we'll use the bus but
we'll not update the memory
because this is a read miss.
>From then on, each write on core 0
will use the bus to broadcast and
update memory, so we get 999 more
accesses to each because of this,
whereas reads are no longer going to
be misses, and they find what they
are looking for in the cache, so they're
no longer going to either bus or memory.
Eventually this cache is replace this.
But nothing happens on
the replacement in this case
because everything is
already up to date.
So overall here we got 1001 bus use.
And 1000 memory writes.
Now let us look at the dirty-bit
only optimization.
In this optimization, the writes on
core 0 will all be happening to core
0s cache and the only write to memory
will be when the block is replaced.
So we get only one memory write.
How many bus uses do we need?
While the first write and every
subsequent write will be broadcast.
So we get 1000 bus accesses
because of these writes.
We still have the one access because the
first read is a miss after that they're
all hits and don't go to the bus.
And now we have an additional bus
access because the replacement
of A here needs to send the data to
memory for which we need a bus access.
So overall, we reduce dramatically the
number of memory writes in exchange for
one more bus use.
Now let's see what happens with
a dirty and shared optimization.
We're right here and at this point we
are the only one who has this blocked so
the shared bit is not set.
This would normally allow us to write
to it without going to the bus anymore.
But because the very next access
is a read of a on core 1.
The sharing starts and
that means that really
we have exactly the same number
of bus uses and memory writes.
Remember that the sharing optimization
only works when we are accessing
a block only on one core.
This block is actually being read
on one core, written on another,
so all the writes on this core need
to be propagated to the bus so
that this core's cache can be updated.
So really here the shared
bit optimization
doesn't result in any savings.